hi reject nation I'm grace stop picking
your eyeballs we're filming gosh check
in with me it's not my job to check in
with you your job follow me these are
real cat you can tell is obviously a
great stand-up comic so good so good I
should follow her on the social medias
which are all in the description boxes
yeah a few people have sent this to me
they are usually followed by this
reactors watching it this reactors which
even in this reactors watch apparently
this bill burr stand-up of white versus
black athletes and Hitler is going
around town and people are doing
reactions to it all right sure I want to
see what the big deal is about and I
figured who better to watch a stand-up
comedy bit with that my one real
stand-up comic friend oh my god you
didn't qualify that with female comic
friend
did I not I'm sorry my one female comic
friend out of my many stand-up friends
I'm sorry bill burr I love I think he's
really [ __ ] funny I've seen a few of
his specials I couldn't really get
through his last Netflix special was not
as great as it was kind of weak sauce
but I still listen to him yeah yeah I
mean still funnier than all over be
anyway let's check it out
[Music]
sports you know like once every four or
five years you know like some 50 to 55
year old white dude tries to explain why
black people are kicking the [ __ ] out of
white people practically in every major
sport you know and it always goes down
to the same way right it's always like
three white dudes and the one white dude
in the middle he's always like the guy
with like the theory you know these are
these African American athletes they all
they see on this side is quick twitch
muscle fire me
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
Christ get out of the way
you ever get tired of those two nuts
flying over your head
you know you're gonna be on SportsCenter
just get out of the way Goodell tell me
there's gotta be some to that theory I
saw this show one time on runaway slaves
it's one of the most amazing programs
I've ever seen in my life doing you
right away is a slam you just shouldn't
run to the end of the driveway you're
gonna like run through whole states dogs
chased me you're hurdle and [ __ ] you're
swimming for the first [ __ ]
triathletes
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Music]
it's like a you know
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Laughter]
I don't get it inside the carpet we're
saying you get fast that's a good thing
right
people start off freaking oh you're
acting like that's all we can do you say
we can't be scientists no I'm not always
saying is if there was a race to the
microscope
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
not anymore sorry if it's all the time
all the time
French my love me like Oaxaca baby town
a black athlete does something they say
it's an athletic move any time a white
athlete does it they say it's an
intelligent move it's like fair enough
man it just just depends on what you're
doing you know I mean it's like you know
you really defense white or black that's
an intelligent move right but if you
take off from the foul line jump over
nine other dudes and throw the [ __ ] down
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
the whole ride home just sitting there
the usual oh you have an opinion you
know I'm really processing this no it's
not gonna be dark and negative never
know again you know I didn't hate bill
burr but I could tell this was done in
the early 2000 what does that matter
matters because comedy has changed
I don't know this video was uploaded
2018 but it's definitely not 2018 video
I want to say this is from his Netflix
special that was on in like circa 2010
well I think you know ever since the
ever since the movie get out 2008 what
did I say yeah you said it's old yeah
and you can tell by the way he's talking
about race why do I do this okay yeah
yeah it's like 10 years old that makes
sense it was funny at the time I think
in the context was it was great it was
hilarious I just retired you don't think
it's funny anymore
me it's not oh god you would you sorry
stand-up comedy brain and your friends
at the Laugh Factory in the comedy store
flappers you know this comb is out just
laugh cat enjoy your life taking the mad
doing Steve if you like stand-up comedy
never do stand-up because it'll ruin it
I think I've gotten that impression yeah
gosh no I mean that was funny bill
birnes one of my favorites play a
hundred percent like he's one of the
ones that inspired me to do stand-up I
think he's one of the most influential
ones in terms of my stand-up style yeah
you're always angry ranting at the crowd
[Laughter]
okay so why I mean I think the stand-up
it's fun I mean I I kept flashing to the
horror movie get out because of it see
ya take you know white guys braid and
put it in a black guy's body if you
haven't seen get out I totally spoil it
for ya for reasons like this having a
more superior athletic body yeah that's
where I was singer but this is like the
funny version of get out is wondering
why it's making the round so much right
now I have a theory on that which is
that we've gotten so PC that suddenly
watching this is like quaint it's novel
we're like oh my God look at this guy
actually making a joke but somewhat
racist and nailing it because it's not
actually racist it's related and we just
don't see that because people shy away
from it so much now ah you know with
your stand-up comedy mind you have
brought some level of nuance to the
discussion where I might have just been
like oh he's a white guy talking about
black people well there's a reason why
we don't see a lot of stand-up that's
like this anymore and it has to do with
sorry Louie CK know with these young
people Oh
snowflakes we're 21 I mean the people
who are even younger than we are talking
about all these 13 year olds of their
definitions about stand-up comedy these
days you can go cuz I've tried to get
colleges to bring me to their college
right and I'll tell them jokes and some
people get it and there
great and colleges colleges colleges
colleges these University students sorry
I just want to make sure if you're going
to a college you say it properly please
continue your actual point do my actual
point I think there's a lot of young
people who wouldn't find this funny but
genuinely they wouldn't get the comedy
they'd be like why are you talking about
this subject matter serious subject
matter
there should be no jokes here I feel
like there be Twitter people who would
say that definitely and those Twitter
people are them the folks who are hiring
stand-up comedians to come to campus
interesting the same group swirly Theory
PC are those students I mean this video
was uploaded like a few months ago and
it has six point three K likes and only
191 dislikes them yeah I'm trying to
fight with you like this kind of comedy
I think they still crave it it's just a
difference of what the industry wants
and what the younger generation wants
and so that's why you're not seeing as
much of it and you'll notice and his
more recent stand-up special like this
kind of an edge is gone like he talks
about like koko the gorilla it's a lot
older now ten years a big difference in
guys I think yeah at the same time you'd
think you'd get more crotchety although
I've watched some of his interviews if
you watch some movies interviews I'm
like Conan and stuff he's pretty
crotchety's yeah yeah definitely it's
like married now and stuff right yeah
she's chilled out yeah I think that's
why it's making the rounds is because
we've kind of lost so much of the stuff
and people are like oh my god and
they're like hungry for it now yeah yeah
no that's a good point that's actually a
really good point yeah but if you're
into the nuances of stand-up I'll tell
you why this bit works and why it's
funny and why it's okay and not racist
okay cuz it's not because of the victim
of the joke who's choosing the right
victims of the jokes and so that's what
differentiates a joke between something
that's a bad offensive horrible joke and
a joke that's funny and okay to laugh at
is who is it making fun of and this is
making fun of the dumb why people yes
correct
it's okay to teach a course of comedy at
the Los Angeles Valley
being a community college professor I'm
actually qualified to teach economics at
Community College combine it with your
comedy talents the only 21 yeah laughter
this is fine just like that was funny
yeah that's why you're here
it's yours it's your job you have a
different angle I mean your job is to
dissect comedy and deconstruct and study
and everything like as is with your
profession it's your job to analyze
through me I don't unless I stand up it
really mesmerizing me then I'll do that
but for something like this I'm like
yeah that's that's part of the funny of
bill burr you could watch show me almost
the funniest person ever and also just
be like that was funny yeah it would
take someone extremely I don't know why
you ever hang out with me like she never
laughs at my jokes
[Laughter]
[Music]
on that note coat check out cat on the
socials of the media's you can subscribe
you the reject nation ring that bell
apparently so youtubers say I don't know
check us on patreon we got a whole bunch
of goodies over there would love to have
you because patron check today